Chemin Roxham, fin d'après-midi.
Ils sont déjà plus d'une
centaine à avoir traversé
la frontière. Plus de 13 000
demandeurs d'asile ont emprunté
ce passage de janvier à mai,
du jamais vu avant l'arrivée
de l'été.
Finalement réunie,
les réjouissances seront de
courte durée pour cette familles
de vaccination ne seraient
pas en règle.
Ces soeurs devront patienterdan,
où elles ont déjà passé
deux nuits mouvementées.
L'Agence des services
frontaliers devra ajouter
des roulottes pour répondre
à l'afflux qui augmente.
Leur capacité passera
de 297 à 477 personnes.
- Ils nous ont mis ici...
- Mahmat, 23 ans, a dû fuir
le Tchad, persécutir
critiqué le gouvernement.
MAHMAT
demandeur d'asile tchadien
- Franchement, j'ai eu peur.
Est-ce que je vais retourner?
Est-ce que je vais mourir?
- Ses deux premiers jours au
Canada, dans une roulotte, lui
sé un arrière-goût amer.
- À la frontière, c'est
la galère. Franchement,
c'est pas facile.
Il y a quasiment rien.
Juste des lits et des draps,
et puis voilà.
La bouffe, c'est pas quelque
chose de très résistant.
- Le goulot d'étranglement,
ce sont les hôtels réservés
par le fédéral. Les séjours
destinés à une quarantaine
de deux semaines se prolongent.
Combien de temps
vous prévoyez rester?
- Hum... Un mois et demi.
- Et la crise du logement
complique la sortie des hôtels.
Les demandeurs d'asile
sont souvent dépassés par
la lourdeur administrative.
CAROLE CHARVET, DG Carrefour
d'intercultures de Laval
- Quand on est sur le terrain,
on est un peu frustré parce que
nous, on vient avec un mandat
particulier qui est celui de les
aider à chercher un logement,
mais on est interpellé pour tout
ce qui précède ces démarches-là.
- Québec accuse Ottawa
d'accepter trop de demandeurs
d'asile par rapport à
la capacité d'accueil.
JEAN BOULET, ministre Immigrat.,
Francisation et Intégration
- Et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on assiste à l'addition
des roulottes, et c'est
évidemment dans des conditions
humaines qui sont discutables."
- Les roulottes ont déjà coûté
plus de 7 millions de dollars,
et leur facture augmenteraavec s
installations temporaires.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hughes,
Radio-Canada,
Saint-B